homelessness is exploding in the state
of California particularly in the cities
and if you've been there recently you
know what we're talking about
according to HUD here in Washington 114
thousand homeless people reside in that
state that's a quarter of the national
total bill Wells is the mayor of El
Cajon California near San Diego he said
that rather than fighting homelessness
lawmakers in his state are actively
promoting homelessness while panhandling
intensities enjoy legal protection he
says the homeless have learned they can
commit petty crimes with impunity which
is shocking to hear mayor Wells joins us
tonight
mr. mayor thanks coming up Baxter Harbor
Tucker it sounds so perverse it's hard
to believe the state of California you
say is encouraging homelessness how well
there's been a legislative philosophy
there's really encouraging normalizing
homelessness and we've seen several laws
that have come by a be 109 reclassified
70 crimes from serious to non serious
and the result of that was about 8,000
people were released from the prisons
and a thousand of those people ended up
on the streets we know that about 10% of
all homeless populations are former
prisoners and that's just one of the
many laws 10% of all homeless in the
state of California are recently
released prisoners yeah you know it's
true you know I I should point out that
besides being the mayor of the city I'm
also a mental health professional I've
done this kind of work for about 30
years I have a doctorate in psychology
and I work in an inner-city ER and I can
tell you that most of the homeless
people that I run across are involved in
drugs and alcohol and a lot of the new
laws have a lot to do with that day
for example proposition 47 reclassified
many of the felonies and as SB senate
bill 180 made it very difficult to send
people back to prison who are involved
in drugs and alcohol and a lot of the
homeless advocates very much want to
ignore anything that has to do with
hinting that some of the homeless people
have drug and alcohol problems when if
you ask any police officer or ER doctor
we'd all probably a 90 percent or above
of people in the homeless population are
drug or alcohol why and it's obvious
when you're there but why would
officials want a lot
about something like that well I think
that homeless advocates really are
trying to protect the system in which
they give away money through various
programs and they feel that if people
feel that the people that are getting
these benefits are drug addicts or
alcoholics they cannot qualify for a
program but what about the people who
aren't homeless but who aren't rich and
just you live in a neighborhood you're
excited to buy the house and all of a
sudden you got a lot of people living on
your street what does it do to their
quality of life it's been terrible for
the people of my city and we've seen
about a 35 percent increase in
homelessness in El Cajon but in the
beach cities I know you're from the
Beach area
and we've seen over a hundred percent
increase in homeless and many of the
beach cities and this has a lot to do
with methamphetamines and the the
increase of drug production this comes
from Mexico and so it's a terrible for
the quality of life
I mean meanwhile cities in California
are cutting down Reese's trees because
that's the the real problem mayor wells
I'm I'm sorry to hear what's happened to
your city and God speed fighting back
against it thank you for joining us
tonight thank you very much